alors l'invitée que j'accueille
maintenant tout le monde en parle parce
qu'il a réussi cette année
un come back triomphale voici patrick
bruel
bonsoir sur l'être dans les églises des
papas bon bah oui moi je suis allez donc
vous voir sur scène patrick début mais
on sait pas revu depuis
je voulais pas trop la joue et animateur
de télé mais enfin c'était vachement
bien j'ai passé une très bonne soirée
d'abord parce qu'il y avait ça
hu
voix
ensuite gérer ça
mais dans tout
tours qui viennent
son territoire
très bien très trop dit
et ça
qu'avez vous le disais j'ai pas content
si je te disais j'ai pas voulu y avait
ça dans la vie
voilà donc au départ déjà il y avait de
bonnes chansons ensuite c'est non on va
voir un concert c'est important j'avais
de bonnes chansons ça aide ensuite à un
moment où je trouve très rigolo vous
mettez une petite casquette de titi
parisien
et puis vous chantez déjà mince j'ai
trouvé ça très drôle
c'était une manière de passer d'une
chanson qui s'appelle elie qui consacre
à mon grand père dans laquelle il assez
difficile de mettre quelque chose et je
suis passé par une autre émotion celle
de la vente saint jean pour aller vers
quelque chose d'un peu plus d'un peu
plus ludique
c'est inattendu nous amuser avec un
accordéon avec mes musiciens qui ont mis
des casquettes puis on a fait un petit
côté gaz est un peu là j'avais la java
la java bleue mon amant de saint-jean la
romance de paris je vais finir comme
yves montand et ce n'est pas le pire
qu'on puisse ôter un artiste verrier une
version inattendue de votre première
chanson pas votre premier tube ce n'est
pas ma première chance en vous parlez de
pétard c'est très agréable
et je fais avec
dans ses mots
lee
mais au début c'était la préversion et
la version mais la maison de disques qui
à l'époque m'avait dit mais ya pas de
cas ça avance mais à la radio salle est
interdite censuré dans nos moutons qu'on
allait changer le texte est réservé aux
gens qui vont au concerts maintenant
d'aller maintenant c'est pour les gens
qui vont concerner ils ont en plus la
fin de la chanson se termine avec une
petite surprise qui se passe à l'opéra
avoir ya un cd me sentais un cd la vie
serait tellement bien quoi faire quand
je suis chez moi mais c'est très beau
courir à la maison mais j'ai peur
d'avoir l'air content si je fais ça à la
télé c'est quoi ça c'est comme ça c'est
nous quand on fait de la pub déjà on dit
qu'on fait de la pub ça mignon ça fait
quoi
non non le côté groupe allège le projet
sinon toi tout seul au milieu il est
très bizarre on peut dire mais voir si
toi tu vas le faire d'abord personne le
faisceau plan graphique
gare alors a causé des tensions
bon lancer cd s'appelle juste avant le
premier single c'était justement tir est
le deuxième single c'est pour la vie est
le troisième single c'est ça
après
ouais
voyez unisson qui s'appelle marie
florence gros qui marque les mères de
famille qu'à 35 ans qui a fait hec et
docteur ès lettres et qui a bossé avec
vous alors j'aime bien savoir comment
vous l'avez rencontrée par un j'allais
dire par hasard en fait non c'est un
jour louis michel colla directeur de la
gaîté montparnasse qui est un garçon
adorable et qui a un métier très très
persuasif qu'a pris son téléphone qui
m'a appelé qui m'a dit tu dois
rencontrer de jeunes quelques unes des
chansons ils vont écrire une chanson
j'ai envoyé une cassette à non non non
non ils viennent chez toi avec une
guitare il chante des chansons je dis
ouais bien sûr j'ai que ça à [ __ ] ils
m'ont dit non il dit il faut absolument
qu'il rappelle qu'il insiste ce qui
l'attend mais j'ai pas recevoir tous les
gens qui ont envie de me chanter des
chansons sinon je fais plus que ça il
m'a dit non mais t'as pas beaucoup à ça
une demi-heure à perdre beaucoup à
gagner
il a tellement insisté il était 11h40
jeudi écoute d'accord mais à midi là
sinon pour ma part ils sont pointés avec
une guitare et puis ils vont chanter une
chanson telles anecdotes comme celle
dont vous parlez dans elle voulait tous
là non non c'est pas la même non
maintenant si elle voulait tout à nos
mails à 35 ans elle est mariée à deux
ans vous laisser comme ça les lieux non
elle voulait tout c'est une rencontre
c'est une rencontre d'une nuit a raconté
un petit peu comment ça s'est passé
quand même parce qu'en plus c'est
autobiographique mais je le raconte sur
scène tous les soirs et josette valat
spectacle et de la chanson un procès
dans la chanson là franchement la junte
à pécho une meuf t'a pas une chanson
c'est l'album alors là on change le sens
et la meuf qui m'a pécho 5 et 10 le sag
et drôle et bien je salue le regardons
les yeux le mat rappelle me fait me
promener dans l'année dans les rues de
caracas
elle m'emmène dans un hôtel me fais
comme tu dis mon affaire au matin lcl
s'étirait je pense qu'elle m'a tout
piqué en fait marié piqué du tout et c
barbier à la même payer la chambre
c'est beau aussi et aussi d'ailleurs
rien et est ensuite des roachs et
ensuite évidemment je me dis comment il
fait pour la laisser partir et je n'ai
jamais revu il est forcément l'avait
d'autres payants en tout temps
justement pas c'est une histoire vraie
l'est justement pas tu veux faut que tu
il faut que tu allais cette part de
romantisme
caracas états unis j'avais pas confirmé
qu'un général c'est le contraire à ces
garçons qui font chirac elle sait que
bien alors l'album en question dans quel
axe appel juste avant il en est à quoi
sept cent mille exemplaires vance à 800
pour un retour c'est bien observé
pendant qu'on pende dans le sang et
alors donc vous avez zénith mais alors
vous êtes en tournée en france jusqu'à
la fin 2000 il ya une soirée pour votre
41 ans ou tous vos amis sont venus ils
ont tous fait des surprises des zones à
vous il y avait pas tout le monde
vincent lindon qu'à chanter pour la vie
pour la première fois de sa vie
phil récente et pour la première fois de
sa vie et là on va regarder donc c'était
donc le 15 mai aux épaules 14 c'est pour
les 41 ans de patrick bruel et là on va
voir la méga roumanie nous